[Musique]
jean michel blanquer le ministre de
l'éducation était en vacances à ibiza
lorsqu'il a dévoilé le nouveau protocole
sanitaire dans les écoles au parisien à
la veille de la rentrée scolaire info
confirmée par le ministère il
travaillait à distance donc pas de
problème il ya des règles qui sont
rappelées à chaque fois par le premier
ministre et son cabinet pour l'ensemble
des membres du gouvernement il faut
rester dans l'espace européen il faut
être joignables en permanence à sa tâche
je n'ai aucune raison de penser que ce
n'était pas le cas de jean michel
blanquer il faut être absolument tout le
temps joignable et au travail je crois
que c'était le cas de jean michel
blanquer qui a travaillé pendant ces
vacances si encore tout ça c'était fait
avait été parfait bien organisée bah on
pourrait dire bon ben ok ils étaient en
vacances mais il a réussi à travailler
mais non c'était pas le cas tout ça
c'était n'importe quoi devant tant de
temps perdu devant l'obsession de la com
devant tant d'erreurs de fonds comme de
forme il est un peu les mini démissionne
oui je demande c'est pas la première
fois je demande la démission de jean
michel blanquer je critiquais jean
michel blanquer quand monsieur jadot se
taisaient moi maintenant je ne demande
pas la démission de toute façon
qu'est-ce que ça va changer est-ce que
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas jean
michel blanquer requis est responsable
c'est emmanuel macron jean michel
blanquer air en dj voilà la première
image ont eu de nombreux internautes en
apprenant que le ministre de l'éducation
nationale avait dévoilé le nouveau
protocole sanitaire à l'école depuis il
vise à votre faute politique n'est pas
d'avoir pris des vacances mais ne pas
avoir fait vos devoirs de vacances en
présentant plus tôt et de manière
concertée votre protocole que dire de
vos consignes incompréhensibles et
inapplicable depuis hier soir les
masques ffp2 réclamé par les professeurs
ont une autre allure et l'on imagine les
réunions hommes du ministre au bord de
l'eau il y as je le reconnais une
symbolique il se trouve que le lieu que
j'ai choisi j'aurais dû en choisir sans
doute un autre la symbolique je la
regrette vous avez dit
bizarre cette période
comme elle était sa réserve il ya
l'hiver on se paye je suis pas le genre
dans la boîte mais ça veut bien dire que
les ministres ont franchi quand ça veut
dire que les seuls moments où tu peux te
payer un appart à ibiza c'est en hiver
est-ce que vous avez démissionné n'ai
pas répondu à cette écoute et on est en
période présidentielle donc je crois que
le mot démission sera prononcée par à
part bien des candidats très souvent je
pense qu'il faut garder le sang froid ça
ne fait que confirmer qu'on a un
ministre qui se moquent éperdument des
enseignants le parquet de paris ouvre
une enquête contre jean-jacques bourdin
le journaliste de rmc et bfm télé est
soupçonné d'agression sexuelle une
ancienne salariée du groupe a déposé
plainte pour des faits qui remonteraient
à 2013 alors c'est vrai que molière by
mettez le doigt sur les petites
absurdité de son époque et basse il
avait vécu dans notre époque je pense
qu'il aurait fait un burn-out où ils se
seraient adaptés et l'aurait écrit le
bon chemin gentilhomme à ibiza âgé de 33
ans la victime présumée qui a travaillé
pendant plusieurs années avec le
journaliste affirme que celui-ci l'a
saisi par le cou et tenté de l'embrasser
à plusieurs reprises dans une piscine
d'un hôtel de calvi les riches sont
devenus plus riches les pauvres plus
pauvres c'est le bilan de ces années
qu'ovide sur toute la planète la fortune
des milliardaires a augmenté de 5 mille
milliards une hausse de 60 % en deux ans
en italie une infirmière a été
interpellé et arrêté par la police pour
avoir fait semblant de vacciner des
patients anti-vaccins regarder ses films
et par les policiers en caméra cachée
désormais toutes les 26 heures il ya un
nouveaux milliardaires dans le monde
mais dans le même temps depuis le début
de la crise sanitaire 160 millions de
personnes sont tombées dans la pauvreté
elle est accusée d'avoir fait ça sur
onze personnes et de leur avoir délivré
un faux certificat de vaccination le
tout pour la modique somme de 400 euros
selon la théorie scientifique l'homme
est placé parmi les grands singes et le
cours qui a posé problème donc c'était
le dernier et pour les espèces actuelles
homo sapiens et le chimpanzé j'utilise
des images actuelles et pour homo
sapiens j'avais choisi pour ce cours là
la photo de soprano